Me dijeron que soy una traidora a mi propia profesión,
que debería ser despedida,
que deberían quitarme la licencia médica,
que regresara a mi propio país.
Mi e-mail fue pirateado.
En un foro de debate con otros médicos,
alguien se atribuyó el "bombardeo" a mi cuenta en Twitter.
Yo no entendía si esto era bueno o malo,
pero luego vino la respuesta:
"Lástima que no era una bomba de verdad".
Nunca pensé que yo haría algo
que provocaría tal nivel de ira entre los otros médicos.
Mi sueño era ser médica.
Crecí en China
y entre mis primeros recuerdos de infancia
recuerdo que me llevaban de urgencia al hospital
y que por la gravedad de mi asma
tenía que ir casi todas las semanas.
Tuve una médica, la doctora Sam, que siempre me atendía.
Tenía casi la misma edad de mi madre,
su pelo era rizado y espectacular,
siempre con vestidos amarillos de flores.
Era de aquellos médicos que,
si te caías y te quebrabas el brazo,
te preguntaba por qué no te estabas riendo
pues era tu húmero
(como "humor" en Inglés). ¿Lo entienden?
Bien, te quejabas
pero ella siempre te hacía sentir mejor después de la consulta.
Todos tuvimos un héroe en la infancia
como quien queríamos ser al crecer, ¿cierto?
Bien, yo quería ser como la Dra. Sam.
Cuando tenía ocho años, con mis padres nos mudamos a EEUU,
y la nuestra sería la típica historia de inmigrantes.
Mis padres limpiaban habitaciones de hotel,
lavaban platos y atendían en estaciones de gasolina
para que yo pudiera perseguir mi sueño.
Llegué a aprender suficiente inglés
y mis padres se alegraron mucho
el día que entré en la facultad de medicina
y cuando llegué a tomar mi juramento médico.
Hasta que un día, todo cambió.
Mi madre me llamó para decirme que no se sentía bien,
que presentaba una tos constante,
que tenía dificultad para respirar y se sentía cansada.
Yo sabía que mi madre no era de quejarse por cualquiera cosa.
Si ella decía que le pasaba algo.
era que debía estar muy mal.
Y lo estaba.
Descubrimos que tenía cáncer de mama en etapa IV;
que en ese momento le había alcanzado los pulmones, huesos y cerebro.
Mi madre fue valiente, y no perdió la esperanza.
Se sometió a cirugía y radiación,
y en la tercera ronda de quimioterapia
fue cuando perdió su libreta de direcciones.
Ella buscó el número de su oncólogo en Internet
y lo encontró, pero también encontró algo más.
En muchos sitios web,
él aparecía como agente bien pagado de una compañía farmacéutica;
y muchas veces ya había recomendado
el mismo programa de quimioterapia que le había prescrito.
Ella me llamó aterrorizada;
yo ya no sabía en qué creer.
Tal vez era el mejor tratamiento para ella,
pero tal vez no.
Le dio miedo y la hizo dudar.
Cuando se trata de medicina,
la confianza es fundamental,
y cuando la confianza se acaba, queda sólo el miedo.
Ese miedo tiene otra cara.
Como estudiante de medicina, yo estaba tratando a un joven de 19 años
que volviendo a su dormitorio en bicicleta,
había sido golpeado y arrollado
por una camioneta 4x4.
Tenía siete costillas fracturadas,
la pelvis se astilló
y sangraba internamente en el abdomen y en el cerebro.
Imaginen a sus padres
volando desde Seattle, a 3200 kilómetros,
para encontrar a su hijo en coma.
Lo lógico era averiguar lo que le pasa a su hijo, ¿cierto?
Pidieron estar presentes en nuestras rondas médicas
en las que discutíamos su condición y su tratamiento,
lo que me pareció una solicitud razonable,
además sería una oportunidad de mostrarles
cuánto nos esforzábamos y nos preocupábamos.
Pero el médico jefe lo negó.
Dio todo tipo de justificaciones.
Tal vez podrían estorbar a la enfermera;
tal vez los estudiantes se abstendrían de hacer preguntas;
hasta llegó a decir:
"¿Y qué tal si ven errores y nos demandan?"
Lo que vi detrás de los pretextos fue un profundo miedo
y lo que aprendí fue que para ser médico,
debemos vestir nuestras batas blancas,
erigir una muralla y escondernos detrás de ella.
Hay una epidemia encubierta en la medicina.
Por supuesto, los pacientes tienen miedo cuando van al médico.
Imagina que despiertas con un dolor de estómago terrible,
vas al hospital,
estás en un lugar extraño, acostado en una camilla,
tienes puesta una bata traslúcida,
hay extraños que se acercan para hurgarte y pincharte.
No sabes lo que pasará.
Ni siquiera sabes si tendrás la manta que pediste hace 30 minutos.
Pero no sólo son los pacientes quienes tienen miedo;
los médicos también lo tienen.
Tememos que los pacientes descubran quiénes somos
y de qué se trata la medicina.
Entonces ¿qué hacemos?
Vestimos nuestras batas blancas y nos escondemos detrás de ellas.
Claro que cuanto más nos escondamos,
la gente querrá saber más lo que escondemos.
Cuanto más miedo haya, este se dispara y se convierte en desconfianza
y en una atención médica deficiente.
No es solo el miedo que le tenemos a las enfermedades,
tenemos la enfermedad del miedo.
¿Podremos arreglar esa desconexión
entre lo que los pacientes precisan y lo que hacen los médicos?
¿Podremos superar esa enfermedad del miedo?
Déjenme ponerlo de otro modo:
si esconderse no es la solución, ¿qué tal si hacemos lo opuesto?
¿Que los médicos se volvieran totalmente transparentes con sus pacientes?
El otoño pasado, llevé a cabo un estudio para descubrir
qué es lo que la gente quiere saber del servicio médico.
No sólo quería estudiar a los pacientes de hospital,
sino a la gente común.
Mis dos alumnos de medicina, Suhavi Tucker y Laura Johns,
literalmente llevaron la investigación a las calles.
Fueron a los bancos, cafeterías,
ancianatos, restaurantes chinos y estaciones de tren.
¿Y qué descubrieron?
Cuando preguntábamos:
"¿Qué quieres saber de tu servicio sanitario?"
La respuesta de la gente era sobre los médicos,
porque se considera que el servicio sanitario
es la interacción entre paciente y médico.
Cuando preguntamos: "¿Qué quieres saber de tus médicos?"
la gente respondió de tres formas diferentes.
Algunos querían conocer la idoneidad del médico;
que tenga su tarjeta profesional para ejercer la medicina.
Otros querían cerciorarse de que el médico no esté sesgado
y que tome decisiones basado en evidencias y en la ciencia,
no en quién le paga.
Lo que nos sorprendió
es que mucha gente quiere saber algo más del médico.
Jonathan, estudiante de derecho de 28 años,
dice que quisiera alguien que se sienta cómodo con pacientes LGBTQ
y sea especialista en la salud de LGBT.
Serena, una contadora de 32 años,
dijo que para ella era importante que su médico tenga sus mismos valores
cuando se trata de opción reproductiva y derechos de la mujer.
Frank, dueño de una ferretería con 59 años,
ni siquiera le gusta consultar al médico
y quiere encontrar a alguien que crea en prevención ante todo,
pero que se sienta cómodo con tratamientos alternativos.
Uno tras otro, nuestros participantes dijeron
que la relación médico-paciente es profundamente íntima,
que para revelar sus cuerpos a sus médicos
y contarles sus más profundos secretos,
quieren entender primero los valores de sus médicos.
Sólo porque los médicos tengan que atender a todos los pacientes
no significa que los pacientes deban ver a toda clase de médicos.
La gente quiere saber de sus médicos primero
para luego hacer una selección informada.
Como resultado, yo creé una campaña
llamada "¿Quién Es Mi Médico?"
que exige transparencia total en la medicina.
Los médicos participantes revelan voluntariamente
en un sitio web público,
no sólo información de dónde estudiaron medicina
y cual es su especialidad,
sino también sus conflictos de interés.
Vamos más allá de lo estipulado en la ley "Gobierno a la luz Pública"
con respecto a afiliaciones con compañías farmacéuticas.
Hablamos sobre cómo se nos paga.
Los incentivos son importantes.
Si vas al médico a causa de dolores de espalda,
quizás querrás saber que él recibe
5000 dólares por realizar una cirúgia de columna
frente a 25 dólares por remitirte a un fisioterapeuta,
o si recibe lo mismo, sin importar lo que recomiende.
Luego vamos un paso más;
incluimos nuestros valores con respecto a la salud de la mujer,
salud LGBT, medicina alternativa,
medicina preventiva y decisiones sobre cómo ponerle fin a la vida.
Nos comprometemos a servir a nuestros pacientes,
pues ellos tienen derecho a saber quiénes somos.
Creemos que la transparencia es la cura para el miedo
Imaginé que algunos médicos se inscribirían y otros no,
pero no tenía idea de la enorme reacción que provocaría.
Una semana después de lanzar ¿Quién es Mi Médico?
el foro público de Medscape
y muchas comunidades de médicos en línea
tenían miles de comentarios sobre el tema.
Aquí van algunos.
De un gastroenterólogo en Portland:
"Dediqué 12 años de mi vida como esclavo.
Tengo préstamos e hipotecas.
Dependo de los almuerzos de compañías farmacéuticas
para servir a mis pacientes".
Los tiempos pueden ser difíciles para todos,
pero trata de decirle a un paciente
que gana 35 000 dólares por año para sostener a su família de cuatro,
que necesitas ese almuerzo gratis.
De un cirujano ortopédico en Charlotte:
"Par mí, publicar las fuentes de mis ingresos,
es una invasión a mi privacidad.
Mis pacientes no me revelan sus ingresos.
La fuente de su renta no afecta su salud".
De un psiquiatra en Nueva York:
"Luego tendremos que revelar si preferimos los gatos o los perros,
qué modelo de auto conducimos,
y qué papel higiénico usamos".
Lo que uno piensa de Toyota o de Cottonelle
no afecta la salud del paciente,
pero en cambio sí la puede afectar tu opinión sobre
el derecho de elección de las mujeres, o sobre la medicina preventiva,
o sobre las opciones relacionadas con el fin de la vida.
Y mi favorito, de un cardiólogo de Kansas City
"¿Más imposiciones del Gobierno?
La Dra. Wen debe regresarse a su país".
Bien, aquí tengo dos buenas notícias.
Primero, esto tiene que ser voluntario y no obligatorio,
y segundo, soy estadoundiense y ya estoy aquí.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
El mes siguiente, mis jefes recibieron llamadas
en las que pedían mi despido.
Recibí cartas en mi casa,
a pesar de no haber revelado mi dirección domiciliaria,
con amenazas de pedir a la junta médica una sanción para mí.
Mis amigos y familia insistían que cancelara la campaña.
Tras la amenaza de bomba supe que tenía que acabarla.
Y ahí fue cuando los pacientes me contactaron.
En los medios sociales, el TweetChat,
que en ese momento llegué a conocer,
generó 4,3 millones de impresiones,
y miles de personas me escribieron para motivarme a seguir adelante.
Escribieron cosas como:
"Si los médicos están haciendo algo de lo que tanto se avergüenzan,
no lo deberían hacer".
"Los funcionarios electos tienen que revelar el origen
de los fondos de sus campañas,
los abogados deben revelar sus conflictos de interés.
¿Qué excluye a los médicos de hacerlo?"
Y finalmente, muchos escribieron diciendo:
"Déjennos a los pacientes decidir
lo que es importante cuando elegimos un médico".
En la primera ronda,
más de 300 médicos hicieron la promesa de transparencia.
Qué locura, ¿o no?
Pero de hecho, ese concepto no es del todo tan nuevo.
¿Se acuerdan de la Dra. Sam, mi médica en China,
la de los chistes tontos y el cabello exótico?
Pues, ella era mi médica,
pero también era nuestra vecina
que vivía al otro lado de la calle.
Yo estudié en la misma escuela que su hija.
Mis padres y yo confiábamos en ella
porque sabíamos quién era y en qué creía,
y no necesitaba escondernos nada.
Tan sólo hace una generación, esta también era la norma en EE.UU.
Se sabía que el médico de la familia tenía dos hijos adolescentes,
que había dejado de fumar hacía algunos años,
que decía que iba siempre a la iglesia,
aunque sólo lo vieras dos veces al año: una vez en Pascua
y otra vez cuando su suegra venía de visita.
Tú sabías lo que pensaba,
y no necesitaba escondértelo.
Pero la enfermedad del miedo tomó el control,
y los pacientes sufren las consecuencias.
Lo sé de primera mano.
Mi madre batalló contra el cáncer por ocho años.
Era una planificadora
y sabía cómo le gustaría vivir
y cómo le gustaría morir.
No sólo firmó instrucciones anticipadas,
sino que, en un documento de 12 páginas, decía haber sufrido ya suficiente,
y que ya era su hora de partir.
Un día, siendo yo médica residente,
recibí una llamada avisándome que estaba en la unidad de cuidados intensivos.
Cuando llegué, ella estaba a punto de ser entubada
para conectarla a una máquina respiradora.
"Pero eso no es lo que ella quiere", yo dije, "tenemos documentos".
El médico encargado me miró a los ojos,
señaló a mi hermanita de 16 años, y dijo:
"¿Te acuerdas cuando tenías esa edad?
¿Como hubiera sido para ti crecer sin madre?"
Su oncólogo estaba allá también y dijo:
"Es tu madre.
¿Cómo podrás vivir en adelante, por el resto de tu vida,
si no haces todo por salvarla?"
Yo conocía a mi madre muy bien.
Comprendía divinamente sus instrucciones,
pero yo era médica.
Fue la decisión más difícil que he tomado,
para dejarla morir en paz,
y llevo las palabras de aquellos médicos conmigo
todos los días.
Podemos enmendar la desconexión
entre lo que hacen los médicos y lo que precisan los pacientes.
Podemos alcanzarlo, porque ya estuvimos allá,
y sabemos que la transparencia conduce a la confianza.
Los estudios muestran que la franqueza también ayuda a los médicos;
si se tienen registros médicos abiertos,
si están dispuesto a hablar de los errores médicos,
aumentará la confianza de los pacientes,
mejorarán los resultados de la salud,
y disminuirá la negligencia profesional.
Esa franqueza, esa confianza,
se volverá importante en la medida que pasemos
del modelo infeccioso de la enfermedad al modelo comportamental.
Puede que a las bacterias les importe poco la confianza o la intimidad,
pero para que la gente afronte
las difíciles opciones de estilo de vida, para abordar asuntos como dejar de fumar,
el manejo de la presión sanguínea o el control de la diabetes,
es necesario brindar confianza.
Aquí tenemos lo que otros médicos transparentes han dicho.
Brandon Combs, un internista de Denver:
"Esto me acercó más a mis pacientes.
El tipo de relación que forjé,
fue la razón por la que estudié medicina".
Aaron Stupple, un internista de Denver:
"Les digo a mis pacientes que soy completamente franco con ellos.
No les escondo nada.
Ese soy yo. Ahora cuéntame de ti.
Estamos unidos en esto".
May Nguyen, una médica de familia de Houston:
"Mis compañeros se asombran de lo que estoy haciendo.
Me preguntan cómo puedo ser tan valiente.
Les digo, no soy valiente,
es mi trabajo".
Les dejaré con un último pensamiento.
Da miedo ser totalmente transparente.
Te sientes desnudo, expuesto y vulnerable,
pero esa vulnerabilidad, esa humildad,
puede ser un beneficio extraordinario en la práctica de la medicina.
Cuando los médicos aceptemos bajarnos de nuestros pedestales,
quitarnos las batas blancas,
y mostrarles a los pacientes quiénes somos y de qué se trata la medicina,
es ahí cuando empezaremos a superar la enfermedad del miedo.
Es ahí cuando se establece la confianza.
Es ahí cuando cambiamos el modelo de medicina,
de uno con secretos, ocultando cosas,
a otro, plenamente abierto y comprometido
hacia nuestros pacientes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)